[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i did
talk to chris maddox the senior nba
writer from sports illustrated i talked
to him
prior to the start of the show and
recorded an interview with him so we
don't address what just happened with
kawhi
or chris paul but i started out asking
him about
some of the coaching decisions made last
night by the milwaukee bucks here's
chris mannix no you're right this was
i think unequivocally one of the worst
losses in bucks franchise history when
you factor in the stakes
and the team they were playing against
and the fact that at halftime they had
a 16 point lead now mike budenholzer has
many critics out there there are have
been many that have suggested he'd be
he should have been replaced after last
season and the way they played
in the bubble so if you were a critic of
mike budenholzer uh
it was a feeding frenzy last night i
mean to not
attack james harden on every possession
i mean you could see him
walking out there dan there was a
noticeable limp in his step he was not
going to be able to stay in front his
defensive philosophy in this game was to
back up as much as he could
and force guys like drew holiday to take
mid-range jump shots to not
attack him uh was just bizarre and on
the other end of the floor
like to not take the ball out of kevin
durant's hands
it's not a a you know genius coaching
philosophy
to do that like to play like that you
saw a couple of days ago
the la clippers made a decision to send
double teams at donovan mitchell
and take the ball out of his hand going
back even further when james harden
was a houston rocket we saw defenses
load up on him
force the ball out of his hands or force
him into extremely difficult shots
the buck's philosophy seemed to be like
let pj tucker defend him
or to foul him and there were i don't
know how many possessions giannis
guarding him but this is one of the
top defensive players in the nba
allegedly why wasn't he getting more
turns
on kevin durant i mean i wasn't quite
yelling at the tv
i was verbally yelling through twitter
um but i had the same
same thought process that the the
coaching decisions made by mike buddha
were just shocking
and then there was another one where
giannis didn't want to take it to the
hoop late he was guarded by
james harden and he shot a fade away on
james harden
he didn't want to take it to the who
possibly get fouled and go to the free
throw line
i get that goes i mean that goes in the
giannis
hall of shame if you will i mean a
couple things on this day like
giannis is a two-time mvp he is a great
offensive player
did the nets send one double team at him
during the course of that game
i saw one situation that it was actually
the situation where giannis faded away
where the nets started to double-team
yeah and then harden waved off the
defender
you've got james harden who on his best
day is probably an average defender
and he was not on his best day in this
one is waving
off a double team so against a two-time
mvp
who's got like six inches and 50 pounds
on him
uh he could so he could defend him
one-on-one and hard and giannis's
response
is to fade away in that situation the
the the decision making by
by giannis was just wild i mean when he
had hardened
at the top of the key he should have
gone at him i think he got gun shy
towards the end of the game
about drawing offensive files when he
had hard in the low post
you have to attack him bully him get to
the rim and yes
get to the free throw line if that's
what it comes down to and then at the
very end
to drop a pass in your bread basket that
good could have given the opportunity
to tie the game i mean this this was one
of the worst games we've seen giannis
play in his career
i just wonder how they respond going
back home in game six
because it it's gonna be one or the
other it's gonna be
we got resolve we got backbone there's
to be a game seven or it's going to be
you know our heads are hanging low here
what do you expect in in game six in
this series
well they play a lot better at home and
they always have historically
during the giannis era so i expected to
come out with some energy
the question is can they build a big
enough lead so that in the fourth
quarter they're not just going mano
amano
with kevin durant which is not going to
work for them in that particular
situation but
in a way dan i look at this game six for
giannis in kind of the same way
i look at game six of the 2012
eastern conference finals for lebron
james not putting lebron
and giannis in the same company but up
until that point lebron
had not won a championship he had been
to two finals
the celtics were his nemesis and going
into game six
lebron and the you know miami super
friends were down three games to two
lebron came out in game six had one of
the best games of his career
up until that point to beat boston on
the celtics home floor this is a
different type of situation
but i kind of see it through that same
lens where giannis
this is his moment this is his chance to
either show
he's one of the best players in the game
or to prove the critics of him right
that he can't be a number one on the
championship team
and if milwaukee doesn't get out of this
round
there's going to be changes there well
the the old dan the only change you
could make though is mike budden
yeah i would i would firmly believe that
would be the case i mean they're locked
in
on this roster they made that holiday
deal uh last off season
and that cost them most of their draft
capital moving forward they signed
holiday
to a max contract it's giannis holiday
middleton you know dante de vincenzo
being out certainly hurts them but we
can't put
this series on that the nets have far
more substantial injuries
that they're dealing with but this is
this is it like this is their group i
mean the bucks are lucky
that they've got yon assigned to that
long-term extension
but i would not expect mike budnos to
survive
a second-round defeat yeah crazy we're
talking to chris mannix the
sports illustrated nba senior writer
hawk 76ers tonight game five what do you
expect
you know i like philadelphia in this one
i mean joel embiid was brutally bad
in the second half of uh game four over
12 missed that bunny
and clearly dan you can tell that knee
is bothering him like
you watch that last play that last
philadelphia possession
excellent play call by doc rivers
excellent execution by almost everybody
and then mb gets it and because he can't
explode off that knee
he just muffs the layup at the very end
that winds up costing them
uh the game i do expect being back at
home
is going to give philadelphia a bounce
ben simmons did not play well
in that game four and beat of course i
think will play a little bit better
on his home floor well i thought the
sixers perimeter defense overall
was pretty good against atlanta so i
think philadelphia
wins that game wins this game six but
man that game four
they blew a really big opportunity to
potentially get
mb three or four extra days rest
going into a conference finals that
could wind up costing this team
if not this series in subsequent series
moving forward
are you all in on the clippers now no no
no no
i'm not i can't be i can't i no
no no the clippers to me
yeah they they still look when they flip
a switch i hate using that phrase
because it's such a cliche but like they
do
they flip a switch and they play great
they did it in games three and four
against dallas they did it in games
three and four against utah i just don't
know what to expect from them
in a game five like would it surprise me
if utah went out
mike conley came back and they won by i
don't know 15 points no
like the clippers are just too wildly
unpredictable i mean
if you're telling me paul george is
gonna play exactly like that in game
five
sure all in the clippers but he's
unpredictable uh
the front court the small lot of marcus
morris is unpredictable i
just i think the clippers did an
unbelievable job of getting back into
the series
in those two games but i'm still not
buying the la clippers
thank you chris you got it